okay so in this video we're going to
talk about making glycogen glycogen
synthesis also known as glyco genesis
like over for a new packaging Genesis of
course meaning to make so what is that
it literally what it sounds like
making glycogen from glucose so
basically we're storing glucose when we
make like kijun okay so when we want
when would we want glycogen synthesis to
occur when we when we we want to store
glucose well it's when we have a lot of
glucose and when we have a lot of energy
a lot of ATP so in the fed state okay so
where does this occur it occurs in the
cytosol of liver and muscle cells okay
so now how do we get this going well I
have your activation of g1 p which is
glucose 1-phosphate before before we
even have that happen we have to get
glucose 1-phosphate and how do we do
that well there's a mutase that takes
glucose 6-phosphate and converts it into
glucose 1-phosphate just moves the
phosphate from the sixth position to the
one position to give us glucose
1-phosphate
now when when we're making glycogen from
glucose we're adding glucose units we're
specifically adding them coming
sort of as an extension from glucose
1-phosphate
but they don't come directly from
glucose 1-phosphate that's why we have
to activate glucose 1-phosphate
so glucose 1-phosphate needs to be
activated in order to actually form the
glycosidic linkages okay and so let's
talk about that so what happens is that
we take glucose 1-phosphate and we
combine it with UCP which is your ideon
triphosphate and we combine these two
two molecules to make UDP glucose okay
now what does UTP look like UTP looks
like this got it up here okay so up here
this is the the u nitrogenous base and
then ribose and then the three
phosphates there okay so we combined
them together and two of those
phosphates come off as a pyrophosphate
which is hydrolyzed into two inorganic
phosphates by pyro phosphatase
and we make udp-glucose the enzyme that
catalyzes this reaction is udp-glucose
pyro phosphorylase okay so and the pyro
phosphatase here that cleaves the the
inorganic pyrophosphate into two
inorganic phosphates actually drives the
the formation of of UDP glucose so this
is an example here of reaction coupling
driving a certain reaction to completion
so just having will close one phosphate
plus UTP going to two UDP glucose in the
inorganic phosphate has a delta g of
zero so it's not really driven to happen
but the hydrolysis of of the
pyrophosphate into two inorganic
phosphate is highly exergonic and so the
overall process is exergonic as a result
and therefore spontaneous okay so we
make UDP glucose now UDP glucose is the
actual donor of the glucose unit in
glycogen synthesis this is the actual
donor of the glucose unit okay so you
might be asking why well yeah why did we
do this to glucose 1-phosphate why would
we create UDP glucose why not just add
the glucose 1-phosphate to an existing
glycogen strand and the answer is that
UDP which is just this portion of the
molecule apart from glucose is a better
leaving group than simply an inorganic
phosphate which is on glucose
1-phosphate okay so the better leaving
group allows the reaction to happen more
red more readily so let's get into the
enzyme that actually catalyzes glycogen
synthesis it's a uniquely named glycogen
synthase so literally quite literally
maker of glycogen okay so what is its
function well it adds a glucose unit
coming from UDP glucose of course right
because we said that's the actual
glucose unit donor adds it to an
existing glycogen chain that's actually
an important piece of information that
existing glycogen chain is at least
eight residues long okay so I'll get
back to to that in that detail about the
existing life is in chain momentarily
and so just just for clarification sake
it adds a glucose unit and it makes like
a gin a certain glycogen chain one
glucose unit longer okay so before we
actually get started when would this be
active well when would we be making
glycogen is during high energy states
right during the fed state I've already
mentioned it but it's just a little
reminder here okay so imagine you have a
glycogen chain here that is some number
of residues long some n residues long
I've only shown two here but you can
imagine that oh by the way I indicate
here that this is not an OHA up it's an
O R group now that's just trying to me
trying to indicate that the chain is
longer than than what I've shown here
I'm just I've only drawn two to make it
so that it's not taking up the whole the
whole page of the whole screen okay so
we start off with that UDP glucose and
this glycogen chain that's n residues
long and so what happens is that the
ouais group on carbon number four of the
non-reducing end of glycogen i'm going
to go through attack carbon number one
on the UDP glucose kicking off the UDP
as a leaving group so the UDP comes off
here as a leaving group okay and then
what happens is that this this glucose
unit here basically gets attached here
to the non-reducing end so that glucose
unit is now here so we had to initially
and now we've got three there now it's
not just three right it was n residues
long but now this glycogen chain is n
plus 1 residues long okay so it's one
glucose unit longer than it was
initially okay
so this UDP that we made it's stories
not really over we need to turn that
back into UTP so that we can have that
previous reaction occur again right so
we can activate another glucose
1-phosphate
so we need to regenerate UTP using that
UDP so that UDP is going to head over
and combine with with ATP and ATP so
it's going to give up one of its
phosphates to UDP to basically turn UDP
into a triphosphate UTP and ATP uses the
phosphate to become a DP this is
catalyzed by a nucleoside diphosphate
kinase and this is an ISO energetic
process right the delta T is zero so
what's important though is that that UTP
that's formed for yeah but you TPS form
there can now activate another glucose
1-phosphate and then we can go through
and add another UDP glucose to the
brackets and change we want elongate it
further so that's basically glycogen
synthase now earlier I mentioned that
this adds to an existing like is in
chain so the question might be then what
if we didn't have an existing chain well
that's when this this this dude called
glycogen geico oh my goodness glycogenin
glycogenin initiates things and the way
I remember that is that there's glycogen
and then in initiates okay I actually
just came with up with that genius
anyway so glycogenin initiates things if
we don't already have an existing lexing
chain so let's look at the initiation of
glycogen synthesis you may be wondering
why I didn't show you initiation of
glycogen synthesis first it's because
it's not it doesn't really always occur
in fact I have it written here so
initiation of Y kijun synthesis occurs
if there's no existing glycogen chain
for glycogen synthase to act on but this
this doesn't always occur because
glycogen may not be totally depleted so
we really think about glycogen synthesis
synthesis we're typically thinking about
synthase being like the rate-limiting
step which I should know by the way so
this is rate limiting and therefore
regulated okay
all right so glycogenin what's the deal
with that so we still have to have
udp-glucose because that's the sort of
donor of the glucose unit but instead of
donating an existing glycogen chain
instead what it does is that an always
group on a tyrosine residue on
glycogenin which is a protein will
actually be the thing that attacks the
carbon number one of the glucose on
udp-glucose kicking off the UDP so we
have that UDP pin that comes off as a
leaving group
now what catalyzes that reaction is is
like a gin and glycogen is an auto
glycosylation like oscillation is just
when something when you add a sugar
moiety to something so auto like
oscillation is self like oscillation
right so this baggage and glycosylated
itself all right
so this is like a post translational
modification of this protein it does it
to himself to itself so now we have the
glucose residue that was right here that
is right here okay attached to
glycogenin okay and so now we have this
non-reducing end available to basically
go through and add more glucose residues
to and of course this UDP goes back and
gets regenerated right like it did over
here okay
it goes to regenerate UTP but now we
have glycogen in with just that one
residue on it so back agenda can
actually auto glycosylated itself some
more and it will continue to do so so
this bit of information here over to the
right glycogenin adds a few more glucose
residues and then a certain point once
it's about eight residues long then
glycogen synthase takes over okay so
in essence glycogenin is is or acts as a
primer so to speak for glycogen
synthesis it kind of gets things going
and then glycogen synthase takes over
okay so now all I've shown you go now so
far is make the making of these alpha
one four linkages right this is an alpha
one four linkage right an alpha one four
linkage what happens at the branch
points
you